hi I'm Pat Thornton I'm the CTO
schrodinger accompany many of you may
not have heard of working on problems
you also may not have heard of but I'm
excited to talk to you about both today
I think there's a lot of interesting
stuff in there even for people who are
from the field so who is shouting or
what do you do those are gonna be the
first questions we're at almost 30 year
old company that is committed both the
fundamental research and applying that
research to accelerate drug discovery
material design our approach to
accelerating drug discovery is to
simulate chemistry on the computer I
imagine that's a very fascinating to a
lot of people in here and it allows us
to make predictions about how drugs will
work in the human body without ever
having to create those drugs in a lab to
test them until much later in the
process I won't have enough time today
to talk about materials design but
there's also a lot of really fascinating
stuff there from OLED design to perfumes
just tons of fascinating chemistry we're
able to simulate in that those fields I
will start with a quick walkthrough of
the agenda one thing I really want to
state up front is I'm trying to present
in a way realizing that most people this
field is completely novel and you don't
know anything about it so you don't have
to know about computational chemistry or
even chemistry for that matter I'm going
to try to break it down into the core
problems of computers but I will also
give some background because otherwise
it's just not going to be an interesting
presentation so first we'll start with
why is drug discovery so harder
expensive you've probably read about
this newspapers talk about it all the
time when this new drug comes out and it
costs $200,000 for a cure for something
and everyone says how can you charge
that much little reference that it cost
billions of dollars to discover the drug
why why does it cost billions dollars so
I'll start with that and then I'll go to
the computational chemistry which is a
field that is really more than 50 years
old at this point but is seeing a
renaissance with with modern compute
I'll talk about Schrodinger solution
which uses the cutting-edge
computational chemistry to solve
pharmaceutical problems and then from
there after that background I'll go into
the compute requirements the real meat
and potatoes and we'll we'll figure out
what GCP is doing that's driving our
science and driving George's artery
faster from in that part talking about
how GCD is speeding up Schrodinger I'll
go through several things I'm not going
to read them off here
but there are many ways the GCP is
really being helpful to us as a company
and as the field and a whole so let's
jump in with this big crazy number there
are more than 10 260 potential drug like
molecules some estimates go all the way
up to ten to the one hundredth or ten to
the hundred and twentieth that is just
an astronomically big number by some
estimates it's more potential drug
molecules than there are atoms in the
entire universe
which is hard to even fathom and we need
to find the best one for each disease
that's a little bit strong it doesn't
have to be the absolute best one but we
have to find a really really good one
for each disease but when you're looking
at that many potential drug like
molecules it's an incredibly daunting
task it's not like a needle in a
haystack
it is a not even an atom in a haystack
it's less smaller than an electron in a
haystack that's how small of a thing
we're looking for
when we're trying to find a good drug so
why is drug discovery as a whole so hard
I just got into nearly infinite chemical
space that's one of the most daunting
tasks in preclinical drug discovery when
we're looking for the right drug before
we take it into human clinical testing
accurate evaluation is really hard even
if you make a guess if I just randomly
I'm able to pick the magical molecule
out of my head and make a perfect guess
synthesizing that in a lab cost
somewhere from hundreds to thousands and
in some extreme cases even hundreds of
thousands of dollars to produce that
molecule so you can test it so figuring
out how to how to test ideas faster and
cheaper can really bring down costs when
you're saying oh let's try to do it
computationally the problems are
extremely computationally hard so it's a
constant negotiation between accuracy
which we may never be able to compute
perfectly or something really really
fast that might have so low accuracy you
can't really make decisions off of it so
that's the the the pull and the push in
computational work and then if you do
all of that right of all your
preclinical work goes perfectly biology
is also really hard
biology is where drug design projects
start because you have to know what
biological target you're going after and
it's also where they end
when they're going into the clinic
you're really testing whether the
chemistry works well in the human
biology and you had theories going into
it but your theories are really just a
hypothesis until you've done large-scale
clinical trial testing and many many the
vast majority of programs actually fail
during clinical testing so even if you
do everything perfect chemically which
is really expensive and hard you still
stand a decent chance of failing because
the fundamental biology is wrong so
that's why it's so dang hard and
expensive so what is computational
chemistry I won't bore you by reading
the entire thing and you've probably
guessed by the name it's using cuter
computers to make chemistry predictions
it's an incredibly hard problem without
using numerical analysis or clever
estimations many chemistry problems are
more complex to solve than the hardest
encryption algorithms we're talking it
is easier to crack the hardest
encryption algorithm than it would be to
get the exact accurate answer for a
chemical question which is really really
daunting so we have to try to estimate
the main goal of this field actually is
to try to get as accurate of solutions
possible with this fast of estimations
as possible why is it so hard well again
we're going back to a nearly infinite
chemical space it the more predictions
than atoms in the universe if you take
that to the next step when you're
thinking about the infinite space that
means it is you know literally
impossible to store if you somehow could
calculate the perfect value on every
single one of those you couldn't even
store them because there's not enough
atoms in the universe to put that data
anywhere so you have to be really really
clever in what you sample and how you
store accurate evaluations is really
hard what I was mentioning a second ago
about how it can be more difficult than
encryption algorithm these are np-hard
problems and very hard in people hard
problems quantum computers may one day
crack some of them but there are a lot
of problems that are just not going to
be amenable to quantum computers ever
just because of the nature of the data
and things like that then you start
talking about how big if it's that hard
for a simple water molecule like I
mentioned here how big it is proteins
are actually huge so if it's so hard
the quantum computers still can't solve
for a water molecule or the fastest
supercomputers are having problems
getting valid values for a water
molecule we're talking hundreds of
thousands of atoms orders of magnitude
larger than water that we need to be
able to accurately predict to make a
drug prediction huge amounts of science
fifty years have gone into accurately
estimating relatively cheaply and then
the compute is is massive and uneven so
that is something that the cloud has
really helped a lot because in certain
phases of a drug discovery project you
might want 50,000 GPUs to be working for
a day or two to get you an answer
quickly so you can drive decisions in
the lab but then you'll have a three
week synthesis cycle in the lab where
you just don't need those GPUs at all
and if you're at a big pharmaceutical
company you might be able to balance it
by having so many projects vying for
that time but a huge amount of
fundamental drug research is done at
smaller biotechs that don't have that
advantage of dozens of active projects
going on so I'm gonna stop from kind of
the more compute intensive description
and do a really quick science break I
know most of you won't know chemistry so
this just looks like three random
pictures on the screen so let's pretend
that our brains or neural networks and
try to do some pattern recognition here
solubility is one of the most important
properties in drug design we've spent a
huge amount of resources trying to
accurately predict solubility solubility
just as a reminder is simply when you
drop a molecule or I'm sorry when you
drop a drug in water will it actually
dissolve into the water if it doesn't
dissolve into the water if it just sits
there then what you have is extremely
expensive brick dust because it will
just sit in your system and go
completely through you without your body
ever absorbing it and using the drug so
you have to find something that's
soluble so looking at it from an image
recognition neural network these are 2d
representations of three different
structures so let's try to guess the
third structure based on to where we
where we already know the answer so the
left one has mediocre solubility it'll
break down in water a bit but maybe not
enough for a drug to be effective the
far right one has no in solubility it
will just it'll end up as chalk on the
bottom of your water
and the middle one kind of looks like
something between the two so it's really
hard to guess maybe it has a little
better solubility than the left one
maybe it has in between but from this
data there's just not much you can do
and while you can train on huge huge
data sets there are some inherent
properties that make it so that it's
really really local and there are these
things called activity cliffs where
changes happen very dramatically in
chemistry that make active learning and
machine learning very difficult to solve
problems like this so you might have
guessed that I was going to give you a
surprise this compound in the middle is
actually very very soluble if you drop
it in water and it comes apart you can
very effectively just go deliver a drug
with this type of solubility so why
what's the difference here so the
insoluble compound to understand it you
have to go to 3d this is taking that
insoluble compound rendering it in 3d
like it is in real life and then packing
it into a crystal similar to how water
packs into ice crystals you can see all
of those blue connections there between
the different copies of the molecule
those blue connections are moderately
energetically favorable so if you have a
bunch of blue connections that might be
enough to hold something together maybe
not forever but for a long time you can
also see the yellow connections those
are very very energetically favorable
what that means is that with all those
yellow and blue connections this
molecule really likes to hold on to
itself it packs really well together and
if it's packed together it's not going
to be tempted to go swimming with water
when water comes around its gonna hold
on to itself if you look in the
moderately soluble molecule you can kind
of get an idea for why it is able to
come apart a little bit you'll see there
are none of those yellow lines that were
really really strong all you have is the
blue lines which is a weaker type of
interaction but there are enough of
those blue lines that still holds
together quite well so what you see when
you take the other molecule which we
don't even have a good crystal structure
structure packing here is that you can't
really pack it in a way where there's a
lot of good energy
there's many different ways you could
pack it but when it ends up that water
comes around there's so few interactions
and water is able to interact with it
favorably that it just pulls it right
out this is really hard to predict with
just 2 D or 1 D data and honestly we've
run a bunch of ML because we're
interested machine learning a lot as
well and even when you take 3d data into
consideration if you're not actively
looking at how the molecules can twist
and turn and move with each other the
simple 3d snapshot is just not enough to
predict this this has been your science
birth by the way I won't try to teach
you any more chemistry today but I
figured it'd be useful at some level to
understand what type of properties we're
talking about now that property
solubility it's pretty tough as I was
just talking about it's actually
relatively easy because solubility at
least is only specific to the molecule a
lot of drug-like properties are how that
drug molecule reacts with giant proteins
or other molecules that are much harder
to predict at least solubility you're
only thinking about that one molecule
it's interacting with but it's also only
one of many many properties we have to
optimize and all of those properties
have to be good if any of those
properties are bad it will kill a drug
and more evil than that is that not only
are these properties typically not
correlated at all but some of them are
even anti-correlated so when you improve
a property it's guaranteed to make
another property worse so you're trying
to find this tightrope between two
properties where you can get it right
inside the range of acceptability this
is long laborious tedious work and when
every guess you have about an
improvement on the molecule reconquer
requires weeks or months and tens of
thousands of dollars of synthesis it
quickly adds up you can start to
understand what the masses of molecules
how hard this guess work is and how
expensive is to try theory you can start
to understand why drug discovery is so
hard I guess that's probably really the
end of the science lesson here but it is
going to go to compute soon I promise
so how does Schrodinger solving this so
we have a massive investment in
fundamental research that's something
we've really focused on going all the
way back we were founded by rich Reiser
still at Columbia in the chemistry
department in Columbia professor um and
and going all the way back to the inning
we've really focused on scientists we
have over a hundred I think actually
it's over a hundred and fifty PhD
scientists at this point who all they do
is try to figure out how these
fundamental physics work on a chemical
level and how we can encode that in our
algorithms the next step from the
science is finding that perfect balance
of accuracy and speed and this is
something both our scientists and a
large engineering force work very
regularly on sometimes that's as simple
as speeding up our code sometimes it's
moving things on to the GPU
but sometimes it's stepping back and
saying on a chemical level what what
things can we take for granted that will
allow us to simplify the algorithm it
wouldn't be robust to everything in the
world but for this problem what can we
simplify so we do a lot of that we do
luckily scale embarrassingly parallel
almost all of these calculations since
you're looking at one drug at a time and
you might want to look at batches of ten
thousand but that allows you to scale up
really really quickly as long as you
have the infrastructure to do so but the
last one then comes back around which is
if you're calculating information on
billions or tens of billions or in the
future hundreds of billions and
trillions of compounds how do you
actually deal with all that data you're
generating and that's a big problem for
us as well and and kind of how that
works is on the very left phase we're
looking at billions I think you can
actually go up to ten to the tenth at
this point where we're calculating very
fast properties on CPUs for billions of
compounds we use some machine learning
and some other simple algorithms to get
that down to a small enough number that
we want to push forward and then we
start these cycles where we improve the
molecule we make guesses we approve our
active learning humans will evaluate the
designs humans will synthesize an assay
and we'll slowly be improving these
properties the goal is to do this cycle
as few times as possible if you only had
to do it once it would be this dream
world where you could you could go from
an idea to a drug candidate going into
the clinic you know within weeks or a
few months that's that's the future
dream right now even in the best case
here you're still doing the cycle
times so this computer requirements that
I was referencing earlier what did it
look like well we have massive scale for
CPU maybe it's not massive scale for
Google but for most of us out there five
hundred thousand CPUs is a lot of CPUs
to be using at once especially I mean ah
that's more than a thousand a person
working in our company to give you an
idea of that scale we also regularly
need a diverse GPU so a lot the GPUs are
actually the workhorses for our most
important calculations we have gotten
relatively far down the filter of
accuracy by the time we we get to the
GPU calculation so we're doing a lot
fewer molecules which allows us to only
and maybe have 10,000 things running at
once instead of 500,000 things running
at once that said is still it's still a
lot of work we are lucky that it's
relatively small input and the final
output is still relatively small and in
terms of its it's terabytes if you were
to keep track of all the data we
generate along the way for those
predictions it's you know in the many
many petabytes of data but luckily we
only really need to save some snapshots
or final snapshots of these trajectories
we don't have to keep all the data
together so relatively small and on the
order of you know hundreds of megabytes
or gigabytes and then only maybe
terabytes out so in the big sense of the
cloud pretty small it's rich dense data
it into that small because we want to
analyze about everything it's not like
the first step is going cleaning a bunch
out we really do want to look through
pretty much all of that data and then
finally how are we actually calculating
things we have very different
requirements sometimes we need GPU node
with only 12 gigs of memory or even less
actually I think we have some six gig
instances and sometimes we need 400 gigs
on the GPU node so the ability the GCP
has to allow you to dynamically pick
your node size is really really powerful
for us so here is an example of a high
memory T for GPU node so this is
something that we used to have to build
in-house we actually originally deployed
this application on an in-house server
because you simply couldn't get
something with a few GPUs and 400 gigs
of memory so I will go ahead
and play this video so what you're
seeing here is we've loaded about one
and a half billion compounds into the
GPUs memory as a subset we have a
secondary screening on the CPU but
allows us to keep a relatively easy
microservice if you will that is looking
over a billion synthesizable compounds
and what what we're doing is we're
saying those compounds on the right are
searching libraries that you can just
purchase them off the shelf you don't
have to synthesize them which is a huge
advantage in early drug design we're
saying okay I'm drawing my IDs on the
Left find the closest thing I can just
purchase off the shelf so we can kind of
guess and experiment with our ideas
without having to invest in custom
synthesis which is very expensive so how
our strategies for executing the big
back ends not that that microservice but
when we're calculating properties for
these billions down to thousands of
really really expensive calculations how
do we handle that so first we have the
hardest that we've done and we have a
team of really good solution architects
and engineers that have built a direct
cloud API so that's how we've scaled up
to five hundred thousand for a really
long time we are developing the
technologies to not have to use the
direct cloud API explicitly but for a
lot of our massive scale we're still
using that what we're moving to right
now is an auto scaling cue system as
much stuff as I shouldn't say we're
moving to as much stuff as we can handle
there we will you know slurm is our
preferred queuing system although we
support many it has some limitations in
somewhere in the order of a couple
hundred thousand compute nodes but
reaching that and taking advantage of it
there's a bunch of other legacy legacy
stuff that you're you're reliant on that
said it's extremely easy for some of our
older applications to run on because
they were built to run on clusters
before the cloud existed the future that
we're building towards right now it is
using kubernetes and gke specifically
I'll go on the next slide I'll kind of
go into the architecture details there
but
we would really like to see a world
where we can think about things in gke
clusters instead of having to manually
do Cloud epi and we're hoping gku will
evolve to the place where it can even
displace queueing systems for a lot of
those tasks the gke setup that I
discussed a second ago so the way we're
typically doing that now is we're using
a Postgres or now I should mention that
when we get to the point of really crazy
compute will almost certainly replace
that Postgres server with bigquery right
now it's just easy to deploy it also
allows us to deploy it in-house if
someone if a customer were to have
in-house requirements the post-crisis
group server and the kubernetes spinner
bring out nodes they hit the kubernetes
api server to bring up nodes we scale up
to as many I forget the kubernetes term
we scale up to as many kubernetes nodes
as we can and then we as that work is
finished it'll kind of give status back
to the Postgres server maybe some very
small number of calculation numbers in
them you'll deposit the files into
buckets so the buckets will be used for
both input now put highly scalable data
storage that's actually one really big
advantage over traditional HPC which
frequently still relies on things like
NFS is the buckets are just really
high-quality scalable data storage and
cheap so I wanted to stop a second say
what what exactly are the GPUs doing
we're using 10000 GPUs I've talked about
physics simulation but what does that
look like also I just really love these
videos I think a lot of people think
they look cool so I figured I'd show one
of these so what this is right here is
it's a free energy perturbation
calculation I won't explain exactly what
that means but basically that's a drug
molecule you're seeing with water is
hovering around it inside a human
protein and when we're trying to figure
out is if we take a drug molecule where
we already know its efficacy and we make
a small perturbation to it will it be
more effective as a drug molecule will
it bind better to the protein this
calculation requires you know here it
says eight hours of GPU time I think the
videos
a few hours old and we have it down to
something like two to four hours of GPU
time thanks to a lot to Nvidia for
speeding up their GPUs but it takes
hours on a GPU to do this simulation for
a single ligand and again go back to
that ten to the sixtieth drug space you
can see how infinite the compute would
be to calculate this for all available
ligands so simulating just that simple
motion those motion mechanics is quite
expensive and we do what we can to
reduce it when we can so that says like
how that's how we keep one GPU busy for
that long but coming up with ideas how
do we come up with so many ideas to keep
all those GPUs busy well this it might
kind of look like motion because it's so
blurred but what this actually is is
it's thousands and thousands of drug
molecules super positioned on top of
each other
preserving the same core on the bottom
so those are all tiny tiny changes up
top and we've enumerated many many
potential drug molecules that we think
might be good we've taken a lot of the
human work out of individually drawing
them by by enumerated a bunch of
different combinations and once we've
done that now we say ok we have this big
group of ones let's run some subset of
these through the physics based engine
on the GPUs so say we've enumerated a
billion like I was referencing
let's filter it down let's run a
thousand through GPUs for several hours
maybe 10,000 for GPUs for several hours
and then when we get that data back
let's train an active learning algorithm
that active learning algorithm will then
take a gas and other thousand values and
just sporadically pick points that are
either good or bad or maybe just
interesting for other ideas and run the
physics calculation on those and that's
how we kind of extend the applicability
domain of active learning active
learning is really good in this space
for interpolation when you have two
things that are just clearly two steps
apart from each other active learning is
pretty good at finding the point in
between them it's not perfect because
sometimes they're surprised physics we
still always double check active
learning but it's really good the the
thing that active learning isn't great
ad in this space is finding truly novel
things when you we come up with new
chemistry that is just going to totally
change the way the physics and the
protein works active learning
just can't guess that because it's never
seen that physics in existence before
with the protein so that's where for
extrapolation you really have to
constantly be running more physics based
calculations
so once we've generated all of that data
what do we actually do with it
let's step back to the beginning of a
drug discovery project and a biologist
has discovered a protein that they're
pretty sure is strongly related to
disease so they've done some lab
experiments and if they knock out that
protein the disease goes away you know
in there
in the lab not in a human being maybe in
a mouse so let's kick off a project
trying to find molecules that could
knock out that protein and maybe those
molecules could end up being drugs how
do we actually do that how much data is
involved and that's what the slides
talking about here we probably want to
start with something in the order of 10
billion new ideas we just we want to do
either high throughput screening in the
lab where they have some special
machines that spend a bunch of fragments
through allow you to get some really
inaccurate course data just to start off
of or if you're pretty confident with
what you have on the computer into it's
called an x-ray crystal structure 3d
data of the protein you can start to do
virtual screening with with just with
just the computer itself without having
to go to the lab people kind of go back
and forth on these two things they're
both fairly inaccurate but they find you
the starting places you need to proceed
but the problem is say you've calculated
these 20 properties for 10 billion
things what do you actually do with this
this is keep in mind this is not a
computer scientists they're usually not
even data scientists this is just a a
chemist that has picked up computers
over the years as they've had to and
we're talking about them having to deal
with parsing you know up to trillions of
data points so this is where GGC peas
bigquery has really been a game changer
for us we're able to set it up so that
our backends can deposit the most
important data directly into bigquery
and people who aren't necessary
necessarily data scientists are able to
interact with that data so bigquery has
gave them given us a lot of great things
so in this example that you're seeing we
have loaded very easy
a 1.2 billion molecules you can see the
the number of rows here and a bunch of
data about it into bigquery now normally
if we're doing this these terabytes of
data would require a non-trivial IT task
that you have to set up a database for
the user these would have figure out how
to interact with it we'd have to pick a
UI that the user can easily figure out
and it wouldn't scale very well unless
we really were committed to making this
great but with bigquery as you just saw
you can execute this really simple query
this basic 5 property 5 drug-like
properties query and it will happen
almost immediately in just a few seconds
so the scalability is like we care more
about the output of this than anything
else we could care about from from a
data based perspective and it doesn't
require very much for the chemist to get
going on it so it really has allowed us
to think about data in a totally
different way this example shows how
complex we can get the first one was
very simple but this example shows us
the again with 1.2 billion we've created
this really complex query and what we're
really trying to do is sort things into
different classes so we've loaded 1.2
billion new molecules in with all of
their data and now we have this query
that allows us to sort those into
different things so you can see here
we've been able in just 5.2 seconds
we've sorted 1.2 billion molecules into
different classes of molecules whether
they're their drug-like or fragments or
things like that the ability to do that
essentially immediately is just an
absolute game changer for our data
scientists so kind of the last really
big GCP feature for us is not nearly as
fashionable as machine learning or
large-scale ABC or even Big Data
honestly it matters a lot for us
especially from the management IT side
security side we just love the project
layout of GCP the isolation is very very
natural the user access management is
great it gives you a lot of options
sometimes too many options but I don't
have too many of them too few and
especially if you're a corporate G suite
user it's just trivial to move people
into
a GCP type cloud interface I personally
find the interface wonderful both the
web UI and the command-line tools I
don't get enough time to do purely
technical stuff anymore so if the
interface is really easy to learn I'm
much more likely to use the tool and I
find both interfaces to be really really
strong I'm not going to give a bunch of
examples here of the interface people
can play with it themselves but but I
did want to highlight that because that
was a really big part of the reason why
we chose TCP just the ease of use it's
enjoyable both for like naive users and
the DevOps experts so to kind of give
the summary here Schrodinger's
computational chemistry platform can
speed up drug discovery and sometimes
that's actually directly correlated to
computational throughput sometimes it's
blocked by lab work and things like that
but there are significant parts of a
project run time where if I just have
the ability to run more computations at
once I will speed up how fast the drug
goes to market and it can literally be
day for day so if something used to take
ten days and it takes two days that
means you get to that clinical stage
eight days faster and it's eight days
faster that drug gets to mark it's
pretty amazing when you when you think
about being able to speed up tasks like
that and the cloud has helped a lot GCP
specifically for all the reasons I've
listed a makes our discovery efforts
faster it makes it more flexible and
that flexibility directly translates
into getting things done faster bigquery
allows our scientists to store and
analyze data that's something that it's
it's kind of funny we're talking about
in the same sentence because it seems
like a totally separate tool but the way
it integrates so well with everything
GCP is doing and how we can reach it
from all of our compute nodes trivially
it has great access controls and all of
that that integrated nature of bigquery
really has been a game changer when
we're analyzing the big data we generate
so all in summation these tools come
together to make GCP just a complete
solution for Schrodinger that that's
sped us up and we've really invested and
then on that note I'm going to go to the
cool video I love to show these again I
mentioned earlier I think people just
like to think about how molecules work
inside your body even if you're not a
scientist and we've done a pretty good
job of making these things pretty
so here's a video that's a few years old
that I'll kind of end the presentation
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and I will end it on that note thank you
very much for watching today I hope I
didn't bore you too much with science
there's a ton of people I should thank
by the way a bunch of our solution
architects helped us out and obviously
the whole company built most of the
software thank you very much